[Music]
thank you
in Philip K Dick's novel The Man in the
High Castle there are two books
mentioned within the novel that play an
incredibly important role one of them is
made up within the novel it's part of
the narrative world and the other is
something that exists in our real
history as opposed to the alternative
history in which the Nazis and Japanese
have won World War II and dominate The
Globe and that second one is an ancient
Chinese classic it's actually one of the
confusion Classics called the E Jing
sometimes written iching right and it's
translated as the book of changes and
there's an entire vast history that
could be told about the composition and
commentaries on that we're not going to
worry so much about that here instead
we're going to focus on how characters
particularly three of them in the
Pacific States of America and also in
the Rocky Mountain States are using this
work and its Associated practices
for the purposes of divination but in a
very broad sense where it has to do not
just with trying to predict the future
but figuring out how to successfully
adapt yourself how to make things better
for yourself or respond to the matters
that are in front of you and
traditionally this is a work that is
consulted through divination so the most
common practices are throwing coins or
throwing Euro stocks and then looking at
what comes out in the throes and coming
up with what are called hexagrams and
there's 64 hexagrams so you can look
through them and each of them has a sort
of Entry or commentary
within the book of changes that tells
you okay you got this now think about
this oftentimes enigmatic and general
you know set of of
statements propositions in some respects
poetry and then see if you can adapt it
to the situation that you're in and this
is very common with divination practices
across the world now there's a very
interesting uh thought process that I
want to begin with here in a character
who doesn't use the E Jing as far as we
can tell
so this is Robert children and he is at
the house of the young hip uh Japanese
couple part of the elite and he's
thinking about the difference between
the Japanese and American cultures in
terms of creativity and he says
even the E Ching which they force down
our throats it's Chinese
borrowed from way back when whom are
they fooling themselves pilfer Customs
right and left where eat talk walk as
for instance consuming with gusto baked
potatoes served as sour cream and chives
old-fashioned American dish added to
their Hall but nobody fooled I can tell
you me least of all and then he you know
he's conjecturing about who's actually
creative and who's not but the point is
here that the Aging has become an
integral part of Japanese culture and
then Americans have picked it up as well
now the first character that I want to
bring up who's not actually the first
character to consult the itching in the
book which would be Frank Frank is
tagomi the you know trade consulate
person and he is pretty devoted to using
this and we're going to see a lot of
very interesting Reflections so chapter
2 begins Mr no nobosuke tagomi sat
Consulting the Divine fifth book of
Confucian wisdom the Taoist Oracle
called for centuries the each anger book
of changes this is how dick is
introducing it at noon that day he'd
begun to become apprehensive about his
appointment with Mr Children which would
occur into more hours and he's worried
about am I going to get a good gift to
give to this foreign visitor Barnes so
he or bains the ostensibly Swedish uh
person who is you know going to bring
information about injection molding
processes but who's actually an opera
spy Rudolph Wegner so he's Consulting
the the oracle
and we get some interesting little back
and forth here Mr tagomi says I inquired
of the Oracle will meeting between
myself and Mr Children be profitable and
obtained to my dismay the ominous
hexagram the preponderance of the great
the ridge pole is sagging too much
weight in the middle all unbalanced
clearly away from the Dao and so this is
not a good sign for him and he goes on
as well and he's uh you know recording
all this he says in Consulting the
Oracle and obtaining hexagram Taco 28 I
further received the unfavorable line in
the fifth place it reads A withered
Poplar puts forth flowers an older woman
takes a husband no praise no blame and
then he's got an interpretation of this
this clearly indicates Mr children will
have nothing of worth worth to offer us
at two
um and you know so this is going to lead
to a sort of problem then he consults it
about about Baines as well he says I
have further consulted the Oracle for
purposes of policy I cannot divulge to
you Mr Ramsey the question it is
sufficient to say I received a most
provocative response
it caused me to ponder at length it
deals with Mr Baines my question
produced through the occult workings of
the Dao the hexagram shun 46 a good
judgment at line six at the beginning
and nine in the second place his
question had been will I be able to deal
with Mr Bain successfully in the nine in
the second place that assured him he
would it read if one is sincere it
furthers one to bring even a small
offering no blame and he interprets this
Mr Baines would be satisfied by whatever
gift the ranking trade Mission grafted
to him through the good offices of Mr
tagomi but notice he also says
Mr Tacoma and asking the question at a
deeper query in the back of his mind one
of which he was barely conscious and so
often when the Oracle had perceived the
more fundamental query and in answering
the other had taken upon itself to
answer the subliminal one too so now we
see here that it's not just a mechanical
process this is an engagement between
the diviner and through the Divination
process and the Dow something much
greater than either and you know it's
going to turn out that his gift is not
particularly well received it's a Mickey
Mouse watch he also does uh an
interesting consultation in chapter six
after meeting Baines and we we get to a
little bit of discussion about this
um so
he says uh which of the or he says this
is not a good day I should have
consulted the Oracle discovered what
moment it is what moment in in the
changes that take place in the universe
I have drifted far from the Dow that is
obvious which of the 64 hexagrams he
wondered am I laboring under opening his
death story brought out the eging and
laid the two volumes on his desk so much
to ask the sages so many questions
inside me which I can barely articulate
with see again this theme of The Oracle
being able to figure out what sort of
answers we aren't asking but really
ought to be asking for right and the
hexagram was 47 oppression exhaustion
and then tagumi says I inquired to the
moment the moment for all of us no
moving Lines no hexagram
not particularly good across the board
then we see he consults it again before
the meeting with the two people in
disguise right and this is in um
uh chapter 10. so
he uh here we go Mr uh tagomi Rose from
bed started towards the bathroom then
changed his mind and went directly to
the Oracle Seated cross-legged on the
floor of his living room and began
manipulating the Euro stocks he had a
deep sense of the urgency of his
questioning and he worked at a feverous
pace until he had the six lines before
him shock hexagram 51 God Appears in the
sign of the arousing thunder and
lightning sounds he involuntarily put
his fingers up to cover his ears haha
great burst that made him wince and
blink what does it mean he peered around
his living room a rival of what
nothing heart pounding respiration and
alsomatic processes
including all manner of
diencephalactic controlled autonomic
responses to crisis adrenaline greater
heartbeat pulse rate glands pouring
throw paralyzed eye steering bowels
loose Etc stomach queasy and sex
Instinct repressed and yet nothing to
see nothing for body to do run
right so dilemma of civilized man body
uh mobilize but danger obscure so this
throws him into kind of a interesting
situation and then we have this
consultation of the Oracle again
after
um tagomi has sort of risen to the
occasion and behaved in what would
normally be looked at in a heroic manner
he has killed the two SD men that are on
their way to try to kill Rudolph Wegner
and presumably everybody else in the
building but he shoots them first and
then he's reflecting on this he's a
Buddhist and to have to take two lives
to save one seems to him a real problem
and it's it's you know he's already kind
of out of whack and then we find
something else going on so once again
still shaky he began taking out the 49
Euro stocks whole situation confusing
and anomalous he decided now notice what
he's going to say next very very
interesting
no human intelligence could decipher it
only 5 000 year old joint mind
applicable
so he this is how he's interpreting the
aging and the the consultation
divination process Consulting a joint
mind uh German totalitarian Society
resembles some faulty form of life worse
than natural thing worse in its
admixture it's potpouri of pointlessness
and you know he's he's thinking about
this and he says the Oracle will cut
through it even weird breed of cat like
knocks in Germany comprehensible to EG
then we see Mr baines's perspective Mr
Baines seeing Mr tagomi distractedly
manipulating the handful of vegetable
stocks recognized How deep the man's
distress was for him Mr Baines
throughout this event having to kill and
mutilate these two men is not only
Dreadful it is inexplicable what can I
say that might console him he fired on
my behalf the moral responsibility of
these two lives is therefore mine and I
accept that I view it this way
coming over beside Mr Baines General
tadeki said in a soft voice you
witnessed this man's despair he you see
was no doubt raised as a Buddhist even
if not formally the influence is there a
culture in which no lives is to life is
to be taken all lives are holy he will
soon recover his equilibrium in time
right now he has no standpoint by which
he can view and comprehend the act now
notice this last line
that book will help him for it provides
an external frame of reference it allows
him to
resolve no longer what's going on in the
future but to resolve his past actions
and the ethical even cosmological
implications of them finally we have uh
tagomi having a heart attack in chapter
14 and remembering the Oracle and
thinking maybe that applies to what's
happening to me here so that's one
really important use uh or sets of uses
of the Oracle by one of the main
characters now we get uh Frank Frank and
Frank is using it for somewhat different
means a little bit similar to uh when
tagomi is using it for his encounter
with with children so Frank is thinking
about how should I approach this guy who
was my boss Windham uh Matson who has a
lot of power but I need to get money
from because he fired me and I I need to
start off on my own what am I going to
do so he asks the Aging how should I
approach Windom Matson in order to come
to decent terms with him he wrote the
question down on the tablet then he
consults it half of the 64 hexagrams
eliminated already soon being expert he
had all six lines the hexagram lay
before him he did not need to identify
it by the chart he could recognize it as
hexagram 15. Shin modesty the low will
be raised up the high brought down
powerful families humbled he didn't need
to refer to the text he knew it by heart
a good omen the Oracle was giving him
favorable counsel and yet as it goes on
he was a bit disappointed there was
something fatuous about hexagram 15.
some to goody goody naturally he should
be modest perhaps there was an idea in
it
after all he had no power over old WM he
could not compel him to take him back
all he could do is adopt the point of
hexagram 15. this is the sort of moment
when one had to petition to hope to
await with faith heaven in its time
would raise him up to his old job or
perhaps even to something better and
then he asks another question
will I ever see Juliana again and what
does he get there the hexagram his heart
dropped 44 cool coming to meet its
sobering judgment the maiden is powerful
one should not marry such a maiden again
he'd gotten it in connection with
Juliana so this is something that is
happening over and over again and then
he is going to consult it again when
he's thinking about whether he should
open his business and this is in chapter
four right after tagomi has consulted
the Oracle so um he gets out his his uh
a copy of the Aging that's in the lounge
or the business office and he asks
should I attempt to go into the creative
Private Practice outline to me just now
throws coins the bottom line was a seven
that so was the second then the first
the bottom trigram is Chen he realized
that sounded good Chan was the Korea
creative than line four and eight Yin
line five also ate a Yin line good Lord
he thought excitedly one more Yin line
and I've got hexagram 11. Tai peace very
favorable judgment his hands trembled as
he rattled the coins a Yang line and
hence hexagram 26 tattoo The Taming
power of the great both have favorable
judgments and it has to be one or the
other he threw the three coins Yin a six
it was peace opening the book he read
the Judgment peace the small departs the
great approaches Good Fortune success so
he realizes I ought to do as Ed McCarthy
says open my little business
but then he looks at some other things
and he realizes that there is a change
and here's how it reads the change
alluded to in the middle of the hexagram
has begun to take place the wall of the
Town sinks back into the moat from which
it was dug the hour of Doom is at hand
it was beyond doubt he's thinking to
himself one of the most dismal lines in
the entire book and yet the Judgment of
the hexagram is good which was he
supposed to follow and how could they be
so different it had never happened to
him before good fortune and doom mixed
together in the oracle's prophecy what a
weird fate as if the Oracle had scraped
the bottom of the barrel uh tossed up
every sort of rag bone and turd of the
dark then reversed itself and poured in
the light like a cook gone barmy I must
have pressed two buttons at once Jam the
works and got the shemalazels eye view
of reality just for a second right so so
he's uh thinking about that and he
realizes that maybe this refers to not
the jewelry business but World War which
is close to the case
then finally while waiting for uh
Windham matson's decision he again is
going to consult the oracle
and we see something very interesting
here so
um he he's he's doing the Oracle the
hexagram is 47. his nose and feet are
cut off oppression at the hands of the
man with the purple knee bands Joy comes
softly it furthers one to make offerings
and libations
so he's he's like ah the money is not
going to be forthcoming I can't start
this business and McCarthy his partner
says you rely on that thing too much
and then at four o'clock a messenger
from the corporation appears and hands
Frank and McCarthy manila envelope when
they open it they find a certified check
for two thousand dollars
this makes Frank think Frank thinks the
Oracle must refer to some future
consequence of this that's the trouble
um later on when it has happened you can
look back and see exactly what it meant
but now well we can start setting up the
shop and there is going to be a bit of
catastrophe happening fortunately in the
end it works out but uh you know it's
pretty dangerous for Frank for a while
finally we have Juliana Frank and this
is very interesting her first reference
is when she's talking to Joe uh who is
actually a secret agent but posing as a
Italian truck driver and former uh
Commando and we hear her saying the only
book I carry around isn't actually a
book it's the Oracle the iching Frank
got me hooked on it and I use it all the
time to decide I never let it out of my
sight and she asked Joe want to see it
want to use it and he says no that's the
end of that and she won't actually use
it until after she has the violent
confrontation with Joe
and slits his throat and she's realized
that he you know is there to try to kill
the author of the other main book
mentioned in this book The Grasshopper
uh you know lies
um and and Robinson is the author of
this and so she has to figure out what
to do she's perhaps kill Joe perhaps not
she knows that
um agents are on their way to kill
abenson and so she consults it
so hexagram 42 increase with moving
lines on the second third fourth and top
places therefore changing the hexagram
43 breakthrough she scanned the text
ravenously catching up the successive
stages of meaning in her mind Gathering
it and comprehending notice the the
language that dick is using there for
the process of Consulting the Oracle on
the part of Juliana right
Jesus it depicted the situation exactly
a miracle once more all that had
happened there before her eyes blueprint
schematic it furthers one to undertake
something it furthers one to cross the
Great Water okay so that's a trip to go
and do something important not stay here
now the lines her lips move seeking 10
pairs of tortoises cannot oppose him
constant perseverance bring Goods
Fortune the king presents him before God
now six in the third reading she became
dizzy one is enriched through
Unfortunate Events no blame if you are
sincere and walk in the middle and
Report with a seal to the prince the
prince it meant abenson the seal the new
copy of his book Unfortunate Events the
Oracle knew what had happened to her the
dreadfulness with Joe or whatever he was
she read six in the fourth place if you
walk in the middle and report to the
prince he will follow
I must go there she realized even if Joe
comes after me she devoured the last
moving line nine at the top he brings
increase to No One indeed someone even
strikes him he does not keep his heart
constantly steady misfortune
oh God she thought it means the killer
the Gestapo people it's telling me that
Joe or someone like him someone else
will get there and kill abenson quickly
as she turned to hexagram 43 the
judgment
one must resolutely make the matter
known at the court of the king it must
be announced truthfully danger it is
necessary to notify one city it is not
further to resort to Arms it furthers
one to undertake something so she
interprets this it's no use to go back
to the hotel and make sure of him it's
hopeless because there will be others
sent out again the Oracle says even more
emphatically get up to Cheyenne and warn
abenson however dangerous it is I must
bring him the truth
and she does this
a little bit later but before that she
phones and Mrs Robinson is on the phone
and she says I'm you know I I'm a fan I
want to come up there and then she tells
her about the oracle
she says the Oracle told me to come to
Cheyenne
and Mrs Robinson says oh my sounding as
if she knew about the Oracle yet not
taking the situation seriously and then
she gives her the lines and
um Mrs Robinson says go ahead yes we'll
look forward to seeing you tomorrow
because she also believes in and uses
the Oracle as does her husband as we're
going to find out but that's another
part of the story these are the main
consultations that are taking place
until we get to the very important
conversation between Juliana and
Robinson about the nature of his book
and the nature of the Oracle and indeed
even their world so the Oracle is
performing some pretty important
functions within this story at least for
the characters who are willing to
consult it and to try to take to heart
what it is that it reveals to them